News about Michelle Schumacher is always
accompanied by the same footage from the
past no fresh images have been released
for a year on December 29th 2013
Schumacher was skiing in the French Alps
he was an accomplished skier and he was
wearing a helmet but he fell and hit his
head on a rock the Formula One legend
was operated on in canola and placed in
a medically induced coma his fans were
quick to show their support when I heard
that Schumacher was in the hospital I
came at once I had to shoe muffets 45th
birthday was just a few days later on
January 3rd his fans held a vigil
outside the clinic we Ferrari fans alike
brothers we are one that's why we are
here to support him as he fights for his
life Schumacher's family thanked his
fans for their support and they continue
to fiercely protect his privacy messages
of support continue to flood in via
social media
fresh rumors concerning his progress
were enthusiastically discussed in April
Schumacher gradually emerged from his
coma in June he left the hospital in
September Schumacher began a program of
rehabilitation at home in November he
was awarded an honorary Bambi media
prize in his absence and the old footage
was rebroadcast the image is recalling
happier times are all Schumacher's fans
have at the moment they're an expression
of their hope that there
we'll completely recover bought one year
on from the accident it's uncertain
whether that hope can ever be realized